le mec qui rentre un peu trop souvent
bourré à la maison ça va et sa femme sa
femme c'est un colosse comme ça le fait
du MMA et tout elle rigole pas elle lui
dit écoute tu rentres encore une fois
une fois bourré et tu vois le gourdin
qui est là tu vois je t'éclate la terre
tu vois alors tu vas faire quoi cet
après-midi et ben il dit je vais prévu
chérie d'aller aux escargots
tu rentres à quelle heure à 16h je suis
là attention
je t'éclate
il en trouve beaucoup et remplit son sac
entièrement énorme d'escargots et se
lever sur le dos comme ça TOI il est
presque rentrer chez lui et 4h45 il est
à 50 mètres de la maison toi et du
bistrot là-bas
le mec il rentre
dans le bistrot 4h05
4h10 4h30 5h
21h
22h 22h
ivre mort
rebond son escargot
se remet seul
direction la maison est il y a un petit
perron tu sais pour rentrer chez lui
avec une marche
il oublie évidemment là la marche il
bute dedans et tout le sac d'escargot se
renverse
je partais devant lui sa femme surgit de
la maison avec le Bourdin lui il regarde
sa femme
il regarde les escargots il fait voilà
on est arrivé
il y a pas plus droit
donc c'est le mec qui rentre chez lui
ivre mort toi vraiment défoncer et
s'endort tout habillé dans dans le
plumard à côté de sa femme et il meurt
ça peut arriver n'importe qui tu vois il
meurt il arrive vers vers Saint-Pierre
toi et il dit il dit c'est quoi ce
bordel là hein c'est qui Saint-Pierre
quoi
je suis mort c'est ça je suis mort je
vous préviens je vais très très mal le
prendre il est pas question que je meurs
moi je veux revenir sur Terre
Saint-Pierre il dit Monsieur pardon mais
il y a des règles il y a un moment il
faut mourir et puis c'est tout dit il y
a pas de mes couilles je m'en fous je
veux revenir sur terre sans bière on
revient pas comme ça et dis-le j'aurais
bien une possibilité éventuellement bah
dis vas-y fais péter c'est quoi bah dis
je pourrais vous faire revenir mais en
animal oui et là j'aurais qu'une poule
mais dis je m'en fous je m'en branle une
poule n'importe quoi j'adore venir s'il
te dit si tu fais
on se retrouve dans une basse-cour
[Rires]
un petit peu du pied
et le coq et l'arrivée vient
l'accueillir ah bah il dit vous êtes la
nouvelle elle dit oui bonjour madame la
poule dis bonjour bonjour
ça va lui dire ça va ça va
je me sens un petit peu
barbouillé vous voyez de niveau du
ventre et le coq lui dire bah ça c'est
parce que vous allez pondre un œuf
c'est normal vous êtes une poule madame
il dit allez-y poussez poussez vous
allez voir vous allez prendre un œuf
je vous l'avais dit ça va mieux
maintenant et la boule elle dit bah ça
va mieux ça va mieux
je me sens encore un petit peu
barbouillard a dit ça c'est un deuxième
ça arrive souvent n'hésitez pas allez-y
pousser madame vous êtes jolie poule
allez-y poussez-vous
un bel œuf un deuxième effet à ce
moment-là le mec qui se prend une grande
tarte dans la gueule par sa femme qu'il
y a c'est pas bientôt fini de chier dans
le plumard
[Applaudissements]
je sais plus je sais plus quoi dire
non c'est quoi jamais l'autre moi
non je connais pas Cyril
[Rires]
mon téléphone je suis pas attendre
il se met à la fin de la guerre et il
était il était conquis par une jeune
femme Russe très très jolie et elle a
emmenée à la Libération à Moscou tu vois
et
45 ans plus tard
90 ans le mec et sa femme lui dit sa
femme russe dit tiens j'ai un cadeau
pour toi lui donne une enveloppe il
l'ouvre et regarde il dit mon amour mon
amour qu'est-ce que tu as fait mais
quelle attention formidable un billet
aller-retour Paris
rencontre et dire au revoir Paris merci
mon amour et tout
il monte dans le train et arrive à Paris
immédiatement dans son quartier mais bon
il reconnaît pratiquement plus rien toi
Anne Hidalgo a fait tellement de travaux
mais quand même il retrouve son porche
il a son porche là en pierre qui n'a pas
bougé et juste en face il s'accorde
c'était sa petite cordonnerie avec la
banane jaune comme ça qui est tout
pourri qui dégouline d'huile de de
vieillesse et tout tu vois et il a tiré
regarde dans son dans son portefeuille
et il a écoute ça paraît fou mais la
garder un ticket en fait tu sais de sa
petite cordonnerie avec le nom et tout
il est presque ému
il rentre il ouvre la porte c'est la
même clochette qu'il y a 45 ans il y a
rien qu'à bouger le petit comptoir en
bois ça sent le cuir et tout voyage dans
le temps toi et comme il y a personne il
dit il y a quelqu'un et il entend une
voix très vieux monsieur dans le fond ça
vient du fond de la réserve et oui
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous et
l'autre il dit oh rien monsieur mais
j'avais laissé chez vous il y a très
longtemps une paire de de chaussures et
le petit vieux d'info dit ah oui les
chaussures
j'étais des chaussures comment
c'était des mocassins en fait ah et oui
c'était pas
des mots
que ça marrant et il y avait le petit
pompon il était abîmé sur les chaussures
gauche j'ai dit ouais ouais
le
petit pont et là le vieux dans l'arrière
vous dit qu'il lui dit alors elles
seront prêtes jeudi
[Applaudissements]
tu peux nous en faire une dernière dans
un instant j'ai le temps de réfléchir
ils nous ont fait une dernière
il est bourré il rentre chez lui avec sa
femme
au lit avec un autre mec et il est
concerné et sa femme a dit fait passer
de gueule là regarde comment il fait au
moins
c'est deux mecs qui discutent au bar
sont bien bourrés comme à peu près tous
les soirs il y en a un Dialo tu dis ma
femme elle me fait chier
mais tu peux pas savoir fais attention
fais pas de bruit un chat regarde tu
traînes tes chaussures tu froisses des
papiers ça réveille
un cauchemar ça doit mais l'autre il dit
écoute moi je la comprends ta femme toi
je vais te le dire tout net je la
comprends parce que j'ai dit pourquoi
m'a dit Monsieur tu es un con
et Dieu comment ça tu peux développer un
petit peu bah dis OUI tu es vraiment tu
es un gros connard je t'ai vu faire tu
rentres chez toi et toi tu te cognes la
tête dans la porte déjà j'avais tout le
monde tu truies ton trousseau de clés tu
mets 20 minutes à trouver la clé
après la serrure alors là tu rayes la
serrure tout autour comme ça pour ouvrir
la porte la porte avec cogne dans le
porte-manteau et que tu te prends les
pieds dans le tapis et tout et comme ça
c'est normal qu'elle te fasse chier
alors dis je vais te dire un truc vas-y
je t'écoute il dit bon là on va sortir
tu as vu on a encore bien bien bourré
d'abord
tant que tu as un réverbère au-dessus de
toi tu prends ton trousseau de clés tu
choisis la clé de chez toi tu es là elle
est là allez devant toi là ta ligne ta
maison tu vas toi et arrivé devant la
serrure de la porte de ta maison bouche
en œil
[Rires]
et pieds
tout doucement là tu vas jusqu'à la
chambre de ta femme
et là
sous la couette
tu glisses sous la couette
de ta femme et là
[Rires]
surtout
pas vomir
pas vomir ça ils ont horreur de ça pas
oh merde tu vas jusqu'à ce qu'elle est
un orgasme des qu'elle a eu un orgasme
tu vas dans la cuisine tu te sers une
nouvelle bière elle dira jamais rien tu
dis tu es sûr mais dis bises que je te
le dis
sors du bistrot elles sont trop sourde
ouvre la porte
[Rires]
la chambre ça va
glisse
10 minutes à trois quarts d'heure
il a plus de salive le pauvre la langue
toute seule je suis continue quand même
il y a un coup
une partie gratuite lui
réglisse
jusque dans la cuisine ouvre la porte et
là
je vois sa femme dans la cuisine
univers qu'est-ce que tu fais là ça va
me faire il y a maman qui dort dans la
chambre
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
j'ai un patron
j'ai un patron un réagisse sous la
contrainte
elle est mignonne
[Applaudissements]